there has been much debate about whether
nickelodeon has been copied by other
studios such as Disney and Cartoon
Network or if they just provided
inspiration for very similar shows stick
around until the end to see a major
copycat project made by Disney that is
pretty hard to deny new to the things
subscribe for our latest videos and
click the like button if you enjoyed
this video
now here are 10 animated shows that
copied nickelodeon disney's puppy dog
pals vs. paw patrol disney's puppy dog
pals seems to be awfully similar to
Nickelodeon's paw Patrol but don't take
our word for it
one fan who blogs about Disney and
Nickelodeon shows goes by the name of
Ray has some pretty strong opinions
about this Ray said it feels as if a
Disney Channel exact win to the Pixar
studios showed them paw Patrol and told
them to make that this critic even
compared the theme song of paw Patrol
with the puppy dog pals song going on a
mission in both songs the dogs slide
down sides as they sing about going on a
mission the bloggers went on to say that
both shows feature rescue pups with
techno wizzy collars and transforming
pop houses one key distinction between
the two shows that the puppy blog critic
pointed out is that on puppy dog pals
the pups can only talk to each other
their human caretaker can't understand
what they're saying he could only hear
barks on paw Patrol Alex and Ryder can
understand their canine friends it's
hard to deny the similarities and since
Disney's puppy dog pals aired four years
after Nickelodeon's paw patrol it's
definitely possible that Disney Channel
used to this Nickelodeon show as
inspiration my life as a teenage robot
and robot boy my life as a teenage robot
made its debut on Nickelodeon in 2003
it's a story about a butt-kicking battle
robot named Ginny who has amazing
superpowers and a tender teenage heart
she bites aliens and bad guys to protect
the planet but what she really wants is
to live like a normal girl she wants to
skate at the skate park and go to high
school unfortunately being a
super-powered robot gets in the way of
her fun Cartoon Network Europe
must have really liked this idea because
in 2005 the aired a show called robot
boy it's a story of a butt-kicking
battle robot who has amazing superpowers
but really wants to live like a normal
boy in the trivia section on IMDB it
says the idea of robot boy came from one
of the creators sons who told him he
wished he had a fighting robot so it
could protect him from bullies at school
but there's no denying the similarities
between the two shows so what do you
think do you think it's a coincidence
that resulted from schoolyard bullies or
did Cartoon Network Europe take a
formula that they knew was working in
the States and turn it into a show for
our friends abroad
you'd be the judge cow and chicken and
Ren & Stimpy Nickelodeon's Ren and
Stimpy originally aired in 1991 it's an
animated show that according to the IMDB
summary focuses on the gross
misadventures of a hyper table and a
stupid tat Cartoon Network's Cow and
Chicken was released in 1997 and is a
show that according to the IMDB summary
focuses on the misadventures of two
unlikely yet somehow biological siblings
to Cartoon Network a bunch of copycats
would be immature and inappropriate but
then again both of these shows are
immature and inappropriate variety was
much more adult about it when they said
that cow and chickens tone and animation
style was akin to Ren & Stimpy yep what
they said other fans agreed in one fan
forum user darkwing PXE said cow and
chicken was cartoon network's way of
competing with Ren's to be another fan
that goes by Admiral Zephyr believes
that even the animation style of cow and
chicken was very reminiscent of Ren &
Stimpy
this has been a hot topic in the fandom
world user judy in disguise said that
Brynn and Stimpy was inspired puffiness
and that cow and chicken was a poor
imitation what do you guys think
inspired or a poor imitation coconut
Fred's fruit salad Island and SpongeBob
SquarePants
while spongebob lives in a pineapple
under the sea
coconut Fred's features animated
tropical fruit characters who live on an
island both shows definitely have that
tropical vibe like spongebob the main
character coconut fred is an
JEDEC big-hearted naive and optimistic
character in pursuit of his dreams while
spongebob dreams of being the manager of
the Krusty Krab coconut fred has various
dreams like being a master at the drums
being a lifeguard and saving the islands
from an erupting volcano
spongebob is a highly absorbent sponge
coconut fred has sweet coconut milk
sloshing around inside his head one
major difference is anything coconut
Fred can think up materializes on the
island but you can't deny the
similarities in these two shows even the
animation and music are similar to
SpongeBob SquarePants but fans weren't
fooled by this inferior knockoff coconut
Fred's fruit salad Islands was
originally scheduled for 13 episodes in
the first season but it was canceled
early after some negative feedback and
poor reception fans saw right through
this poor imitation it just goes to show
that kitchen sponges and zany sea
creatures are more compelling than
talking fruit looks like Nickelodeon got
it right the first time
Team Umizoomi and pegan cats team
umizoomi originally aired on Nick jr. in
2010 it's an animated show involving
preschool math concepts fans follow
six-year-old Milly her eight-year-old
brother Geo and their friendly robot
named BOTS
these mighty math superheroes introduce
young viewers to the concepts of
counting measurement shapes and patterns
they use their mighty math powers to
help their friends in Umi city seems
like a pretty fun and educational show
it's no wonder a similar show popped up
on PBS KIDS called peg and cats in this
animated series peg and her pal and
sidekick cats encounter unexpected
challenges that require them to use
preschool math and problem-solving
skills
Team Umizoomi is computer animated that
gives it a glassy feel whereas peg and
cat has hand-painted backgrounds and
hand-drawn characters if you look
closely you'll see that everything is
drawn on graph paper which gives the
show a very unique feel
timo Mizzou
real kids as characters in their
episodes which is something tagging cats
is differently music is very important
to the creators of peg and cat - while
the makers of peg and cat may have used
team umizoomi for inspiration they ended
up with a show that has its own distinct
whimsical style and we can't be mad at
that the loud house and too loud this
comparison has been the source of a
heated debate in the fan verse one fan
dared to ask the question is too loud a
ripoff of the loud house cue the
explosive comments wow people sure do
get passionate about the loud house in
this video
Vale ski from 94 presented the facts and
asked his followers what they thought he
said that the names of the shows are
similar both have the word loud in the
title and both feature of big-headed the
white-haired boy IMDb describes to loud
as a show about two big-headed loudmouth
kids who get into high jinks while
working at the library according to IMDB
the show came out in 2017 which is a
year after the loud house first aired
the loud house is a show about who can
mount an 11-year old boy who lives with
ten sisters who tries to find new ways
to survive his huge family wah the
plotline is different if you hold the
pictures of the main characters
side-by-side it seems that DreamWorks TV
took some inspiration from Lincoln loud
Jordy fans think a couple of the fans
agreed with vas Kibum 94 that too loud
was a ripoff of the loud house but most
fans said they didn't think it was feel
free to discuss this controversial topic
in the comments below
The Fairly OddParents and pixel pinky
The Fairly OddParents is a Nickelodeon
show that features Timmy Turner a
ten-year-old boy who has been picked on
a lot by his babysitter he summons his
fairy godparents who have the power to
grant his wishes some of his wishes are
helpful but others cos are pretty big
mess Timmy's godparents must remain
hidden from his parents during their
adventures the series started in 2001
and has a ton of fans and why not the
concept is fun and interesting that's
probably why in 2009 blue rocket
productions created an animated
Australian British Canadian TV show with
the same concept meet pixel pinky she's
a genie who can make a little girl named
as wishes come true Nina and her friend
Annie have to keep pixel pinky hidden
away from others cheese that sounds
awfully familiar a genie or fairy
godparents who grants wishes for a kid
and must remain hidden that's pretty
similar don't you think one big
difference is the ratings while Fairly
OddParents has rated seven point two out
of ten on IMDB pixel pinky rated as an
unfortunate one point nine out of ten
maybe the Australian British Canadian TV
viewers weren't ready for wish granting
genies or they just don't like copycats
Rocko's Modern Life and the amazing
world of gumball
Rocko's Modern Life and the amazing
world of gumball are loved by fans for
their wacky oddball grotesquely surreal
characters the characters are prone to
exaggerated expressions and find
themselves in all kinds of crazy hijinks
episode after episode
Rocko's Modern Life is an old school
Nickelodeon show that aired back in 1993
it still has a pretty major fan
following it features a wallaby named
rocco his dog's spunky and his
dim-witted pal heifer as i deal with the
messy challenges of modern life the
amazing world of gumball is a Cartoon
Network show that got its start in 2011
it follows a cat named gumball and a
goldfish with legs named Darwin
Watterson as they deal with the messy
challenges of everyday life both shows
have an all-inclusive feel with the
characters that have distorted features
and strange equalities we're not the
only ones who put these two shows
together a fan named Brandon from the
Bahamas drew this awesome fan art with
the caption saying his art was about two
great shows coming together as one
the artists friends agreed commenting
that they wish this would happen for
real and that nothing can beat Rocco's
and Gumball's awesomeness do you agree
with these hardcore fans rocket power
and wild grinders the makers of the
Rugrats created a fast paced show in
1999 called rocket power according to
Nick comm rocket power is the story of
four friends who are addicted to action
and
extreme sports auto rocket and his
sister Reggie and their house twister
and Sam excel at just about every
aggressive sport he can imagine extreme
sports extreme fun and extreme friends
that's rocket power then in 2012
Nickelodeon's sister company Nicktoons
came out with a show that was created by
and a loosely based on professional
skateboarder rob dyrdek
the show was called wild grinders it's
an animated series featuring a group of
skateboarding kids led by lil Rob Rob's
friends include his dog me t his
inventor friend goggles and his other
Powell's known as the wild grinders so a
show about a group of skateboarding kids
on one show and a group of skateboarding
kids on another show but you know if you
make a copy of something it's just not
as sharp as the original that might be
the case here
rocket power stayed on the air for five
years and got a six point nine out of 10
rating on IMDB while wild grinders only
survived for three years and got a
measly one point nine out of 10 rating
the Penguins of Madagascar and the wild
okay technically the Penguins of
Madagascar is a Nickelodeon spin-off of
the DreamWorks film Madagascar but
here's something interesting
after Madagascar came out Disney produce
something very similar called the wild
to be fair both Madagascar and the wild
are films but the resemblance is too big
to ignore let's start with the plots one
story is about zoo animals escaping and
going on a wild adventure to journey
back to their homeland
wait what fans were quick to point out
the similarities in the two films one
fan said that if you saw the previews
and thought this movie would be an
inferior ripoff of Madagascar well you'd
be right another outraged fan said this
is a clone of the worst kind divert -
one thinks that if any other company
dared such as shameful plagiarism it
will be flooded in legal actions so what
do you think did the wild flat-out copy
Madagascar or was it a strange
coincidence which animated shows do you
think copied Nickelodeon leave your
answer in the comments that's all for
our video thanks for watching the things
next time
[Music]